Charlie Harper what do you feel is the
biggest drawback that keeps the bigger
distributors from buying specials well
I'll tell you what Netflix told me they
said we got a lot of hongki's a lot of
straight whitey but if you're selling
out like 2,000 seats or more we'll have
you because that means they can
guarantee views so be a minority get in
the wheelchair be fat have something or
get famous and then go and become a
stand-up um or just get a following if
you get a following in you're only
become some youtube queef that will help
you know go get a huge youtube numbers
and then sending your special they'll
buy it they're just they're just
business people there's their suits yeah
they just want number num they want
money they want views so if you don't
want to do it the long way
that's your route hey how brother and
sister if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips